well let's kick off with joe biden's
pledge ahead of cop 26 that the u.s will
double the money it's making available
to help developing countries cope with
climate change very good evening to both
of you george why don't we start with
you first i'm sure you heard the
announcement great news isn't it
well sort of i mean finally the
government of the us is making good
pledges which are what are they now 12
years old um and to be honest it
scarcely touches the sides i mean this
is a massive amount of investment
required to help poorer nations
it also should represent just a small
part of the huge climate debt which rich
nations owe to the poor ones due to the
impacts of our greenhouse gases
well hang on a minute george it's
doubling climate finance to 11 billion
dollars it's a huge amount of money and
it and it's good in the sense that it
shows that the us is leading the way but
also that the uk is able to make a
difference ahead of head of cop 26.
well look any increment in money is good
but it's still i mean it sounds like a
lot it is a lot but it's tiny i mean
really really tiny when you think of all
the nations which are already suffering
climate crises right now and are going
to suffer much worse climate crises as a
result primarily
of the greenhouse gases that the rich
nations have produced so we did this to
them
and this is a very small reparation by
comparison and also far too little money
to actually help them out of the
emergencies which we've landed on them
yeah um juliet let's get your thoughts
on this this is what president biden
said earlier let's remind ourselves he
said it's a chance for each of our
countries to invest in ourselves and our
own futures uh are you confident that
this money even if it's not enough will
be spent wisely and won't be fritted
away
oh my goodness no way i mean it's
already got shades of austin powers
around it you know these huge just
numbers said what do they mean where
they're going where's this money going
what's being done with it um what are
the strings attached because you know
however money circulates generally and
certainly from the wealthy polluting
countries there are strings attached
they want to see return on investment so
i would love it a lot more if i could
hear where that money was going they
were investing in in the education of
women in remote rural areas which is
actually tackling one of the the biggest
challenges causing climate emergency how
people ask you know well it tackles uh
population situation women get married
later they have fewer healthier children
they're better equipped to deal with
extreme weather um they contribute
better to the economy so these are the
kind of conversations i want to hear and
i also will get much more excited when i
hear about the perpetrators the
polluters instead of these gestures and
giving money to the poorer countries
saying this is how we're bringing down
our emissions these are the numbers and
this is how we're doing better instead
of sort of trying to do that
that leads very nicely um on to my next
question actually uh president bolsonaro
of brazil he said today we do hope
industrialized countries will actually
fulfill their commitments to climate
funding i mean juliet there's an irony
there isn't there that he is lecturing
the rest of us on how to tackle climate
change
absolutely look i don't want to hear
about these pleasures and these
commitments i just want to see the
numbers of of emissions being brought
down from the industrialized ways of the
wealthier countries um rather than this
sort of atonement and whatever you want
to call it offsetting almost
we really want to understand how the
causes of the climate emergency are
being are being tackled
you